hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast cost-effective DNA
methylation analysis by multiplexed
reduced representation bisulfite
sequencing presented by paul data
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
burns and sponsored by dodgy note dye
GNote is a leading global provider of
complete solutions for epigenetics
research biological sample preparation
and diagnostic essays based in Liege
Belgium and Denver New Jersey the
company has developed new insights into
epigenetic studies and offers the
innovative bio Reptar sharing and IP
star automation instruments reagent kits
and high quality antibodies to
streamline DNA methylation chip and chip
seek workflows the company's latest
innovations include a full automation
system the industry's most validated
antibodies and the mega ruptor sharing
system for long fragmented generation in
sequencing and services for our RBS and
chip seek from diet denotes founding in
2003 in leach the company is expanded
rapidly diode opened its US branch in
2006 and developed a global distribution
and partnering network the company plans
to extensively develop its range of
innovative products in both epigenetics
and Infectious Diseases markets to learn
more about diode please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window if you
need to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located in
the lower right finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation properly please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button lower left to let us know that
you're having a problem now I'd like to
introduce you to Paul babbling on Paul
dot winger is a PhD student in the lab
of Christos Bach at the Center for
molecular medicine of the Austrian
Academy of Sciences in Vienna and
developer of a high-throughput
rrbs protocol available as a kit from
dye genome
he studied molecular biology at the
University of Vienna Manchester and an
Imperial College London besides
developing new technologies for
next-generation sequencing his research
interests revolve around epigenetic
modifiers networks and epi genome
editing by exploiting the CRISPR caste 9
system amounts from the presentation
over to Paul Thank You Brenda for the
kind introduction
and I would also like to thank the
audience for your interest in my talk
today about DNA methylation analysis and
broadcasting this life from our lab in
Vienna Austria that's the Center for
molecular medicine I'm at the moment
working as a PhD student in Krista Fox
lab and therefore we have a huge
interest in DNA methylation analysis so
the topic of today's talk will be a
protocol developed to do it in a highly
multiplexed fashion but for those of you
interested in the bioinformatics
analysis of RBS data and also have a few
slides at the end to show you that
there's actually a variety of existing
tools you can use to take care of the
analysis in the crystal Bach lab we are
very much interested in epigenetic gene
regulation and you all know that here
were 200 different cell types in the
human body yeah basically utilizing the
same DNA sequence but epigenetic
mechanisms allow
and eggs on top of this DNA sequence
until now all the different phenotypes
that you can see in the human body so in
epigenomics research we often use the
term the epigenetic landscape to define
a cellular state or to define a certain
development stage to the cell ism and we
see the epigenetic landscape as a sum of
all the epigenetic modifications that
can work inside the cell but in fact
it's important to note that the
epigenetic landscape is something that
we never had very access to so we cannot
just do an experiment to measure the
entire epigenetic landscape but what we
do instead is we select epigenetic
modifications that we think can give us
the most information about the cells
epigenetic state and we imagine the
epigenetic landscape to be organized in
layers of different kinds of information
such as for instance histone
modifications you know that the DNA is
not existing naked inside the nucleus
well it's actually wrapped around
nucleosomes to form chromatin and this
generates areas that are more tightly
packed and areas that are more open and
accessible and yeah the nucleosomes have
histone tails that can be modified by
histone modifications for instance this
is a very important layer of epigenetic
gene regulation but also there is a
sense that we can do to just profile how
open chromatin is such as ataxic but the
layer of information we have been most
interested in and that will be the topic
of today's talk is DNA methylation so
why are you being interested in DNA
methylation in the first place DNA
methylation is a very stable epigenetic
mark luckily for us it exists on genomic
DNA so in this picture here you can see
double-stranded genomic DNA and DNA
methylation is a small methyl group on
cytosine bases directly on genomic DNA
and this is a huge advantage compared to
histone modifications or other
epigenetic modifications because genomic
DNA and also the methylation information
is very stable and this is allowing us
to profile DNA methylation in samples
that are very rare or very precious such
as skin sample collections or
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded the
sample volume environmental samples
that's often maybe do not have the
highest quality so this is one advantage
but what's also interesting about DNA
methylation is that it is the only truly
methodical heritable epigenetic mark for
which a mechanism for its propagation
during cell division has been described
it is also gene regulating and has been
shown to be disease relevant for
instance up to date there hasn't been a
single cancer that was sequenced which
would display completely normal in male
methylation patterns so and also in the
logical disorders DNA methylation and
DNA methylation modifiers seem to play a
crucial role we can also measure it very
accurately using a chemical conversion
protocol which is existing since decades
it is called
specified conversion and I'll talk about
this a bit later during my talk first of
all let's look in a bit more detail what
DNA methylation is so I already said it
exists on genomic DNA and in fact it is
cytosine bases that become
methylated you see that at carbon
position number five there is a methyl
group added to form 5 methylcytosine
and this action is catalyzed by enzymes
which we call DNA methyl transferases
and in humans there's two different
types of these enzymes first of all
there is enzymes that catalyze the noble
methylation this is required to set up
new methylation patterns during
development and biogenesis so and those
enzymes are called Steen mp3 a and 3b on
the other hand there's a second process
called maintenance methylation which is
catalyzed by dnmt1
and it's basically happens during cell
division when DNA methylation patterns
in the parental strength are propagated
through the doctor cell but DNA
methylation is also highly chemically
relevant and I just wanted to select two
examples from my own research
the first example which you see in the
picture on the left is a project that my
boss mr. walk-around did a few years ago
together with collaborators in Manila
Stella's group in Barcelona and
essentially if they were dealing with
cancers of unknown primary origin
those are rare cases of cancer where
intestine is found somewhere in the body
but it's not entirely clear where it
came from so what's the origin of the
tumor was and you can imagine that such
tumors are very hard to treat because we
do not even know which cell type we are
dealing with so Christopher and his team
they use DNA methylation patterns that
they profiles in the metastasis that was
found and could use this algorithm to
predict accurately what cell type the
tumor came from and this is nowadays
used in clinical trials to inform the
treatment of patients so le methylation
has a huge diagnostic value the second
example which you see on the right is
from my own work very early on when
you're honest
christo.pas club I was working on Easter
leukemia and I was interested in
differences between diagnosis and
relapse I was interested was there
epigenetic mechanisms of drug resistance
that we could find on the basis of DNA
methylation and in fact I was able to
identify gene sets that were
differentially methylated between those
two damn tampons diagnosis and relapse
and we were able to relate this to the
drugs that were actually being used for
treating those patients so both in that
Gnostic diagnostics but also following
the treatment of the patients
Hema methylation is a very good marker
and luckily for us and for anyone
interested in DNA methylation there is a
wide variety of methods we can use to
so some of them have a higher genomic
average are usually more expensive
others have a higher throughput of
energy so we generally distinguished
mapping technologies and discovery
technologies from validation
technologies or even technologies we
used to look at biomarkers and patients
and I think we have the opportunity to
do a poll for the audience so I would
like to take this opportunity to ask you
which technologies you have been using
or planning to use in your lab this is
the Infinium area by alumina or is it
already pacified based methods like IBS
or chinampa spot sequencing restrictions
and based methods or affinity enrichment
based or are you completely new to DNA
methylation analysis and just interested
in learning more about it okay
I think we are slowly getting in to the
results of the poll okay I think we can
now push them out but okay thanks a lot
for voting to everyone okay so the
results actually a bit surprising to me
you have to say because I was expecting
what people to use the infinium essay
which is my query based technology by
Illumina and I'm also happy that a lot
of people are new to DNA methylation
analysis so and some of you are even
using our BS already thanks a lot for
voting I hope that I will be able to
convince you that RPS is actually worth
while setting up in your lab and using
for large-scale projects okay so back to
the slide this is an image that I took
from a review that dates back to 2000
ten buy it earlier and back then the
situation was quite different by the
facts based technologies like RBS or
whole genome basket sequencing they are
considered the gold standard because
they give you seen based resolution of
DNA methylation but on the other hands
at least in 2010 the sequencing costs
associated with them were so high that
this was severely limiting the
throughput
so people back then were mostly using
the Infinium microwave platform as a
very cost-effective means to do
large-scale methylation studies in
Bollywood would hope to convince you
today is that in recent years on one
hand sequencing costs were dropping but
on the other hand we also managed to
increase the throughput of our LPS quite
substantially to make it an attractive
method also for large-scale studies but
in order to study DNA methylation we
first need to know where we can find it
in the genome and this is very
interesting
so I'm depicting genomic DNA here and
DNA methylation at least in somatic
cells is happening exclusively at cpg
dinucleotides so cpg dinucleotides a
seed that is immediately followed by chi
in the 5 prime to 3 prime direction and
only some stem cells show or yeah I mean
that there's some exceptions to this
rule but I would say in somatic cells
usually 99% of methylation events happen
at cpg dinucleotides
and you see that I depict some of them
methylated and others are methylated
those
cpg dinucleotides they are not
distributed randomly throughout the
genome but they are biased in regions
that be called CPG Islands the reason
for that is that a methylated cytosine
has a certain capacity to mutate to form
a team this is actually the most common
form of mutations in humans and is
considered a signature of aging so
evolution has made sure that cpg
dinucleotides are kept in regions that
are non-coding but
our regulatory where they can exert
their epigenetic function and to show
you how biased the distribution is I
would like to introduce very quickly a
measurement of CPG density basically we
are just looking at the CPG we are
calculating the distances to neighboring
CPGs and we're taking the minimum and
when we've got this you can see this is
not a random distribution this is very
biased towards short distances meaning
most of the CPGs which are the sides of
DNA methylation are very close together
and if you think about next-generation
sequencing which many people also know
as shotgun sequencing that we break the
whole genome into pieces and by
sequencing very short pieces and
connecting them back by alignments of
them to find the original position in
the genome where that came from you can
see this is just not a very efficient
way of mapping DNA methylation because
the CPGs are not distributed randomly
and a sequencing costs drop maybe in ten
years five years from now we might alter
whole genome password sequence even it's
a great technology is certainly the gold
standard but at the moment it is just
really a little bit too expensive it's
probably about ten times more expensive
than the method I'm introducing today
reduced presentation bias about
sequencing in reduced representation
pacified sequencing will be used in
enzymatic enrichment step and
restriction enzyme that cuts most in
regions of high C between density and
the fragments we get can be size
selected and precise selection for the
very small fragments this allows us to
narrow down the sequence into regions of
the high CPG density especially CPG
Islands and we can get away with just
sequencing in five percent of the genome
in humans for instance but we get 80
percent of information from CPG Islands
which regulates gene expression so I
think that's yeah quite but an efficient
enrichment for those regions and I'd
like to go into even more detail because
I really want you to understand how to
make
that works and that's actually not so
complicated at all so we starts with
genomic DNA and we cut with the
restriction enzyme called msp1
msp1 was the following motive CC
teaching and what's very important to
notice when we cut with msp1 like I'm
showing now we do not use this enzyme to
enrich for the methylated unmethylated
state but what we do is just we cut open
the DNA at sites of DNA methylation no
matter whether they are unregulated or
methylated and we are just making sure
that the beginning and the end of each
of the fragments we'll start with the
information that we want which is a cpg
dinucleotides and I'm just focusing on
one fragment now to explain the process
of library preparation in order to make
this compatible with Illumina sequencing
we have to introduce some common
sequence to it for instance for
next-generation sequencing we need the
sequencing primer that will bind so each
of the fragments and read the sequence
but now which is that a random fragment
so we need to ligate sequencing adapters
so the fragments and we start out by
repairing the ends this is done by just
filling reaction with an enzyme because
we have a five plan overhang with
infinity in at the same time we can
provide excess ATP and we can use a
mistake that the polymerase makes which
we call a tailing so by providing the
polymerase with excess ATP we can make
sure that an additional a nucleotide is
added to each fragment and later this
allows us to like it and adapter
containing all the sequences required
for NGS which has the complimentary T
away and this adapter can also have a
barcode so that we can tell samples
apart even if we mix them so in here in
this fragment would be ready for
Illumina sequencing but we haven't dealt
with the methylation information yet
in order to turn the methylation
information into something we can detect
by sequencing we need to do a chemical
conversion reaction which is called
pacified conversion and it's a very old
chemical reaction that will convert by a
three-step process cytosine to uracil
but at the same time it leaves only
keeps methylated cytosines unaffected so
actually what we're doing here is we're
turning an epigenetic difference into a
genetic difference and then we can read
it with normal sequencing so the last
step of the protocol is a pci
enrichments this helps us on one hand to
amplify our material but also resolves
the Fox structure that is required for
the adapters because we need to be
straight specific and in the end a
cytosine will first be yourself but then
during PCR strands the complementary
strand will have been a but Pierce with
uracil and stem this will turn the
original cytosine to 18 so we're looking
at C 2 T conversions here whenever
cytosine was unmethylated but when the
cytosine is methylated it remains a C
and at the time when I started using
this method there was already
publications out there describing how to
do it actually very detailed
descriptions as well but in the end this
was a final outcome and we were not very
happy with it so when we do next
generation sequencing before we commit
the library to sequence and before we
decides that actually we want to spend
the money to get the sequences for this
library we usually loaded on yeah a
micro Phoenix device that can give us
the precise distribution of the library
and at the same time we were also
simulating the size distribution of an
MSP one digested human genome on the
computer and MSP one has this it
sometimes forms satellite bands they
think that's because of repetitive
elements in the gene
which attack patterns we want inform a
lot of pregnancies exactly the same size
and for human for human genome there
were three set of events predicted but
in our library only family to and we
found those are the natural to and
eventually missing out on a lot of small
fragments and those fragments have the
highest CPG intensity we also saw
actually they're not getting very big
fragments
either and we decided to do two
optimizations which I think helped make
this protocol a success first of all we
wanted to keep even the smallest
fragments and we found that we could
actually leave out a lot of cleanup
steps but then in our BS what's very
quickly is a step that is called size
selection depending on your project
depending on your research question you
want to select a very specific range of
fragments that gives you a certain
genomic feature for instance or if you
wanna focus on CPG Islands only you are
happy with the smallest fragments if you
wanna extend into modern emic regions
like enhancers you probably need bigger
fragments so depending on the research
question we can adjust the size
distribution of the library and for this
videos magnetic beads the combined DNA
and the painting may the presence of
trodding reagent which contains high
salt and sporophyll ink icon and
depending on the ratio of crowding the
agents to sample we can very accurately
select four specific sizes and this is
probably one of the most requested
slides that I made a lot of people ask
me for this slide because it's the
choice how you can control the size of
your library using different bead ratios
and doing different kinds of spray
cleanups
the second improvement we made to the
protocol concerns specified conversion
the actual chemical conversion step
convert a cytosine to uracil we found
that this is actually a very very
destructive process for instance what
I'm showing you here is a quantification
of a library when we make libraries we
can do qpcr
my models will find the sequencing
adapter and this qpcr tells us how much
of the library we have in our tool I
mean we can do this before we do the
best effect conversion and afterwards as
well and comparing the cycle numbers we
found that the difference was more than
10 cyclists imagined in each cycle
you've doubled your amount of material
so this is a huge material loss and we
were actually using one of the standard
kits standard protocols from one of the
big manufacturers in the end we found
that thermal cycling for instance was
one of the key improvements we did we
found that we by cycling between
temperatures we were actually able to
convert much more efficiently this
allowed us to get away with lower
concentrations of reagent and in fact
below its temperatures and so on we
didn't leave almost any of the
parameters unchanged so and Indians the
difference in to PCR cyclists for our
protocol today is just 5 and you will
see the effect of this in this
comparison on top we did the original
protocol that was published at the
bottom you see our improved version of
the protocol with the two new
improvements first of all no in apps to
elaborate preparation bet decisive
action to give us very small fragments
you see now for instance all three setup
ends there but we also improved the best
web conversion we made it much less
aggressive but still wanted to convert
their efficiently and you see very big
fragments as well
big fragments in RBS are not a problem
because I showed you earlier
msp1 fragments always starts immediately
with the methylation information so we
don't really need to read a lot we just
need to read the end and therefore lead
fragments they are just read like any
other small fragment but they give us
information from outside of CPG Islands
and the improvements of the protocol are
also reflected in the data quality that
we get the original RPS protocol is
files I remember was described with 1.5
million
which is a nucleotides you have for the
human samples human genome has 27
million cpg dinucleotides and in fact
our new protocol gives you four million
cpt is routinely
if the quality of your samples already
so if you're familiar with those genomic
features I think it's also quite
interesting to look where do we get the
CPG coverage and of course as expected
most of our coverage is in CPG Islands
and in promoter regions but surprisingly
they also get very good coverage in for
instance exonic regions in eastern 3
k-27 associated regions which are active
enhancers and active regulatory elements
of the genome we get coverage in France
Krypton factor binding sites and this is
looking exactly at the transcription
factor binding site we get coverage in
dnase hypersensitive regions which are
open regions of chromatin with a
regulatory role so actually also for the
proposed dynamic functions of DNA
methylation like regulated enhancers
regulating splicing regulating or
keeping a record of transcription factor
binding we actually see coverage for
those regions without protocol but one
crucial point for us was to metal
protocol that could work also in
large-scale projects for instance we
were very interested in doing projects
of patient material such as
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded samples
which would yeah where we were to
hundreds of patients at the same time so
it was important to us to have a very
high throughput and I think the protocol
can really be classified into two stages
the first stage is fast it is where you
make the library but the second stage is
very very intensive where you have to do
pacified conversions when you to
enrichment PCRs and you amplify your
library where you do the fantasy and
pinups this is a very intensive stage so
they introduced a queen step
between I already told you that the
library adapters we are using have
illnesses on them and this allows us to
pool samples together before the work
intensive steps and we are doing this
based on qPCR data so after the library
operation which we just do in the
96-well plates without peanuts we do a
quick selection and banana to a qPCR in
food service together based on how they
perform throughout the protocol which
the qPCR tells us and of course tend to
have adapters that can be combined but
then all of the other steps can be done
with minimal effort in tubes and this is
actually yeah timing of the protocol for
the technician it takes five days but
this is I think a very feasible timing
that I'll be giving here they won't miss
just sample normalization and digestion
for instance so it gives a really enough
time for each of the steps to in
properly I think even if you were doing
it for the first time you could manage
to complete it within five days and the
picture on the right here showing the
libraries and the size distribution is
intended to show you how we producible
the libraries are there are all of the
same size and look like very high
quality lattice and I'd really like to
thank our excellent technicians are
medical and you are Mahalo who have done
the RBS protocol on so many samples so
actually they did over 3,000 samples
from nine countries and I think it was
probably a bit over 20 projects that
they were taking at the same time and
this of course gave us the opportunity
to do it on very different kinds of
samples different qualities different
species and in general just different
experimental designs that require
different coverage different sizes of
libraries to be selected
and at a certain point we just realized
that we cannot keep up with the demand
anymore like people are asking us for
projects but we do not have enough time
to take on all of those projects this is
when we decided to team up with diagonal
and I really want to thank an Tomas who
has had first developed the protocol
into real product and basically it is
now for sale on the diode website as a
kid I think since I showed you the
quality of data we can get and the
throughput we can achieve the situation
is not very different from 2010 the
first slide I showed you I think in 2016
RBS is really yeah has been catching up
a lot with micro based methods such as
the Infinium si and the 100 fair
comparison here comparing the current
implementation of the infinium chip
which covers 850,000 cpg dinucleotides
and I'd like to compare it to a protocol
which covers four million cpg
dinucleotides
so you already see you get five times
more cpg dinucleotides from the RBS
protocol and at the same time what we
always liked about reduce presentation
files about sequencing is that there is
no prior knowledge involved so we get an
unbiased representation of the cpg
dinucleotides
and it's not selected in any way by
prior knowledge I think this is very
important to look at regions that are
not very well studied so that you can
find new mechanisms and get new ideas
and I think it's especially interesting
with the recent discoveries in the field
of email imagination there there's very
little known about making use of
imagination may be approximately sizes
informal a box ascetism if this is
interesting you it would be compatible
with reduced presentation bias by
sequencing as well and I think then it's
really worth looking into the new
regions but like any microarray based
methods in Phenom si is suffering from
batch effects as well and as a
next-generation sequencing based and
pacified conversion based method RBS is
just more robust
I've been teaching
to six people at least and the results
were always very comparable and robust
also we can get away with twenty five
times less material if your sample is
really good you can make a successful
library with just 10 nanograms and this
is the very important to our clinical
collaborators who of course have
collected samples over decades and they
wanna base this lid of the material on
on the methylation ban it's possible to
keep it for the future this has also
allowed us to do formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded samples if any samples
which is the standard for our banking so
often those collections of LPS after
state pay they date back over decades
and with Infinium area usually you need
a restore kids to make it work but our
best we can do it without modifications
to the protocol
another topic of Infinia means it's
human only so there's no most version of
it if you're working in any other
organism and i think this is the biggest
limitation otherwise for human because
it came out in 2016 the selectivity is
probably quite solid and according to
the newer knowledge but who knows when
it will be updated the next time and the
cost per sample there this is certainly
an advantage of Infinium that is still
slightly cheaper than hobbies' but I
think IBS can can offer more detail if
you're willing to pay a bit more for it
actually maybe if you're a clinician and
you're not planning to do library acts
on your own not planning to do the
pre-processing of the data
I'd also like to mention that just like
for Atheneum there is solutions for RDS
where you can get either kids or there's
also a service let's maybe look a little
bit into this this is the diode website
where they are selling the kit in both
24 reaction and the 96 red chip one that
you can you can get this kit if you want
to do libraries very fast as I said it
takes five days but you can also get the
analysis as a service so if you don't
want to do the analysis
keeping it all kinds with words and very
interesting thoughts the differential
methylation analysis directly as a
service but I also wanna yeah hoodie I
wanted to put in some slides for the
benefit patients amongst you because I
think that the analysis part is probably
what scares people away from using the
next-generation sequencing based methods
like IBS I want to show you that there's
actually a wide variety of existing
tools you produce and that it's really
not so tricky after all but since I'm
not I don't know how much you know about
the technology behind Illumina
sequencing so what kind of data we
actually producing attack so very
quickly go over the process of Illumina
sequencing so that we have an idea of
what the data is generated and what it
looks like and this is really just one
slide so the Illumina sequencer is using
a technology called sequencing by
synthesis and this is happening on the
flow cell the flow cell is essentially
just offensively a slide with
oligonucleotides that are spotted onto
the gas slide and those illegal
nucleotides can serve as Primus during a
PCR amplification so essentially when we
load a library onto a flow cell with
alerts the library a lot so that
actually there is the molecules are
single molecules on this gas slide and
then we utilize the oliver's on the flow
cell to an illegal process called caste
amplification which is required to
amplify the signal that we detect in the
end and custom verification will make
thousands of molecules or the first one
molecule that ended up at a certain spot
but all of the sequences are identically
to the original molecule then our
sequencing primer combined to Augusta
and it is extended cycle by cycle by
blocked fluorescent molecules and only
when we want to initiate the next
sequence in cycle the d-block the
nucleotides there and we can couple the
next one and essentially
the machine is taking pictures of the
flow cell during this process cycling
after cycling and you can see the class
this year as yeah bright dots that were
rested a certain yeah wavelength
depending on which face was incorporated
in this cycle and if you go through the
images and this is done by the software
automatically it does space calls and it
gives you the sequence for each of the
casters so and there's a read coming out
of each of the casters
if we summarize the results thanks T's
for all the bases we get overall cycles
for an RBS diary you can see the pattern
on the right first of all the library
starts with the restriction site for
msp1 which is a
TGG or CTG depending on whether the sea
was methylated or not and then you can
see an overall allocation of C's because
of pacified conversion many seeds are
not methylated many are not in the CPG
context so it usually this completely
drops down but we have more T's instead
because we convert them into T's this is
what an RDS library looks like and then
the data pre-processing really just
requires three steps and this is
actually data so the sequences you can
see here is actually data that I just
copied out of the pom file and you get
spam file from the sequencing facility
so up to here you don't even have to
worry about the process I just wanted to
tell you the background behind it but
from those sequences actually we have to
do three steps first of all it with
libraries because we have very short
fragments some of them some of the
fragments of all the inserts are smaller
than 50 bases and we're sequencing 50
bases into the pregnant so this means
that we will actually sequence through
the fragment in some cases and already
sequenced sequencing adapter that's on
the other side and this is what I'm
highlighting in blue here so we need a
process called adapter trimming and we
also use this to do quality training low
quality bases are not very useful to us
and we trim them away as well and
there's existing tools to do the job
which are pretty much similar through
adaptive training in any other NGS based
application the second step is a bit
more special it is Tiananmen step we
want to find the position of the reeds
within the reference genome and we use
special aligners because we are dealing
with as well converted reeds and the
best part where the reeds have
mismatches of course if you convert to C
to a tee it will be a mismatch to the
reference and we need the lioness the
continuity's in fact the alignment looks
like this you can see the rates they are
all stacking up on top of each other
because they start at the restriction
site and the sequence for exactly 50
base pairs this is why the basically now
are on top of each other and the third
step finally is methylation colony where
script goes really into the details it
dives into the reeds I'm just showing
this year as an image on the right side
you'll see sequencing reads that were
mapped to the genome and you see that
some bases are highlighted for instance
in the top sample this is two samples in
the top sample there is mainly T's and
this means that there was only
unmethylated cytosines which were
converted by the basic lab conversion
into T's the bottom sample however has
methylated cytosines as well you can see
that six of the positions are protected
from conversion and they still show up
as a scene so really as bad conversion
and RBS it's a space resolution they can
really tell exactly what at what place
the methylation event happened and we
can also do very very accurate
measurements if you have enough reeds
because this is basically a digital
readout it's either methylated or not so
we also get absolute values and the
methylation column will in the end in
the table that skips you a cpg
dinucleotides
it's chromosome its position on the
chromosome and it's methylation value if
you want to learn more about existing
tools but in a methylation I can
recommend this video that was written by
my boss mr. pop back in 2012 but it sits
right up to date I have to
say or to cut it short I'm giving you
also list of our favorite tools for the
various steps for instance for step one
for the reach we mean we like to use
three low Matic or trim the lower there
are great tools for step two the
alignment we really like to use PS map
this map is also a great liner
they are both specifically made for a
bicycle converted data and the last step
is methylation calling they are most
people of custom scripts you can get
ours from github because it was
published along with you Hamilton
Commons paper on reference free the
anaemic relations if you go to this
github page you can find the script
called by Sigma calling that can do the
job but just also existing tools and
they're convenient hosted go beyond just
a pre-processing of data one tool I'd
still like to highlight is called iron
beets it was developed by PhD students
of Christopher my boss and but is also a
group leader at the Max Planck Institute
for informatics and this package is
called higher needs it's based on the
statistical programming language are and
is organized in the modular fashion so
different modules can do the data import
the quality control pre-processing also
very interesting plots for you they can
do differential methylation whatever you
like it makes it very easy to analyze
simple experimental designs like
treatments treated untreated or
different groups of patients and it
makes very little brats that can be used
in a publication immediately there is
one last topic I wanted to touch on I
think it's just three more slides
because there's also a lot of people
interested in doing evolutionary studies
they wanna study the evolution of the
epigenome and epigenetic mechanisms and
DNA methylation is a very accessible
mark and therefore top choice to do so
and in fact the other project that was
mainly headed by Hugh Hammond who come
on with the help of a MIDI to clean the
lab and they have done are the s
libraries using our protocol on many
many different animals
and I'm showing just a few examples you
can see it's very that a diverse
selection species and also the DNA
quality was quite mixed for some of the
animals they were just found like after
weeks in the wild but the protocol can
still feed with those samples and
generate berry Goods rbs libraries you
can see the species specific set the dye
plans that they miss pollen generates
they're always different for any species
you're working on and they are usually a
good criterion for the quality of your
library if you have a good quality
library you will see very pronounced set
will advance you can also simulate this
on the computer to make sure that it's
the expected pattern but as you might
have realized some of those species they
do not even have a sequence genome and
this is the program that you have a soft
as well by a clear approach
she called web 3d MA this is an
algorithm she recently published in
several bots in 2015 and it does
reference free differential methylation
analysis so if you're working in an
organism without sequenced genome you
can still use RPS you can still do
methylation analysis the way it works is
basically this based on the fact that
the reads were obvious they start at the
same position I know they start the
restriction site of msp1 and therefore
becoming faster it's based on their
seafood similarity even though we don't
really know that they come from in the
genome and this is what your Hannah does
in the first step
she casters for easy mobility and from
each cluster of reads
she uses a consensus sequence and
thereby season tease suppositions value
of both season TV are treated as
equivalent and they're written to no
consensus as a see then in the next step
she builds instead of a reference genome
into the ghooost reference genome which
then can be used just like any reference
genome would be used to align reads to
get methylation holes from it and from
the host methylation course we can then
do either sequence multi-phase
this is methylation creasing a certain
transcription factor binding site for
instance or we can cross-reference those
regions where we see differential
methylation with many innovative genomes
that human zebrafish Mouse and so on
good I think I'm right on time this
brings me to the end of my presentation
I would still like to thank a lot of
people because the project at this scale
it just would not be feasible without
their help first of all from our lab the
christo.pas Club in Vienna I would like
to thank you Hanna newcomer who is done
most of the interest in downstream
analysis for the RBS State and come up
with this interesting very DMA algorithm
I would like to thank Emily Google and
Johan de hablar to great technicians who
worked on the RBS on over 3,000 samples
very successfully I'd like to thank
Matthias Farley who has helped me in
developing the method especially with
the bicep at conversion and my thanks
also go to the band at the sequencing
facility that we have at SEM the one
spends more on Piper in shows like
Camilla who have a lot of expertise now
with sequencing high bias levels so if
you might still obvious levels yourself
and you're still looking for a
sequencing facility which you've
extended to obvious biomedical
sequencing facility would be a good
choice as well also thanks to the
invitations at the Max Planck Institute
for developing our needs and last but
not least through the team at diagonal
who helped us develop it develop this
into an extra product and keep out there
and also service to ya head people
basically starts using ideas
so thank you very much for your
attention and I would be ready to to
answer some questions you have the
questions
you're right Paul we do have a lot of
questions I just want to remind our
audience they can submit their questions
which they're doing a great job by
clicking on the green Q&A button typing
a question into the box we'll get right
to your questions we have an attendee
who asks Paul how would you expect this
methodology to be different when dealing
with non-model organisms with no
reference genomes so talking about
talking about the better protocol this
is not different at all we do exactly
the same steps exactly the same protocol
only the analysis is different and there
I can yeah bid recommends to read your
Hamilton comments paper instead reports
which contains a detailed description of
the algorithm she's using and there's a
github site with the project where you
can get all of the code she tested it
all so that it works if you download it
it will work on your machine and she's
also very helpful person so of course
feel free to contact her all about this
but in terms of the better protocol this
would be the same maybe you would
probably depending on the size of the
genome of the organism you're looking at
you would may be combined with more than
six samples if you have a small genome
you can get away and you can do much
cheaper sequencing as well so genome
size is yeah cannot can also help you
make it even cheaper I hope this answers
the question okay on to the next a
little bit of a continuation is the
modified protocol available to the
public
yes I would think so um but yeah if you
want to get it set up it's easy and
quickly as possible I would still
recommend the kids probably because it
just takes some time to get get the hang
of it but yeah contact us anytime also
about the modified four
thank you our next question can you give
us more details about which samples are
possible to analyze frozen samples ffvp
samples do they need any special
treatment
okay so in fact we can do both fresh
frozen and every piece empress with the
same protocol so we do not modify the
protocol when we do so um there's a few
things to keep in mind it is a
restriction based si and the most
important step is cutting the genomic
DNA with msp1
so one limitation is your genome cannot
be fragmented already so there's a
certain size limit usually we say that
fragments have to be 2,000 bases or
longer for a successful library
preparation and foremost FFP samples
this is also the case of course what
will happen well if your fragments
already that Chetta are already randomly
fragrance it then this those fragments
will also be suitable to go into the
library preparation and you will have
again the mix of whole genome sequencing
and reduce the presentation as a bat
sequencing so the integrity of genomic
DNA is important but as long as the
fragments are longer than two thousand
base pairs you should be fine and then
there's some limitations as to which
buffers the DNA has to be in but all of
this can be resolved by changing the
buffer or by clean ups and also I wanted
to say that the input amount you need if
your material is perfect probably you
can get away with 10 nanograms usually
really recommend 100 nanograms and in
extreme cases very good in a might be
degraded maybe every piece you might
want to increase this to 200 nanograms
buts but that stays on okay
moving on to our next question if one
has multiple rap raps per treatment
group to save cost would you recommend
pooling samples within the treatment
group for our RBS analyses okay so it
depends on the size of your sample set
but what I would never do for instance
is to have a pool that is untreated and
the other pool would be treated so this
should be always mixed in a random
fashion and this is also how we set up
the protocol because the way we pull
samples is random it's just based on the
performance of the sample during an
elaborate operation so usually we end up
with random mixtures of the treatment
groups but yes it's important if you
pull samples not have one pool with one
condition at the other pool with the
other condition otherwise yeah maybe the
conversion efficiency is a bit higher
for the one polling and for the other
but generally the method should be
robust enough but it's just not not a
good style to design an experiment
everything okay
moving on to our next question what kind
of tissues did you use to compare
methylation patterns between
differentiated species okay I'm not sure
if I get this right but I think the
question refers to the different species
are short in the end rat and that was
really a variety of tissues we had brain
liver I think we had heart muscle so
lots of different tissues that we
extracted for this experiment actually
you are not expected them
okay another attendee asks why would
this only work for vertebrates do you
know if it could be adjusted to work
with non model invertebrate species okay
so the limitation of doing this
invertebrate samples relates to the
phenomenon of CPG Islands which to my
knowledge occurs mostly in vertebrates
and RPS is based that on this idea that
there are certain regions which have
lots lots of cpgs so this is why we
recommend to do it on vertebrates if we
would have to simulate is actually on
the computer how it would work in
different non vertebrate organisms it
can be done for instance if you know how
to use R this is a good package I'll
call TS genome you can trade your own
genomes there and you can simulates the
digestion on the computer and look at
what it's the protocol good to so the
good thing about our bases you can
always simulate what it would do on the
computer before you start doing it
because it's really the captain
efficiency is almost a hundred percent
and you get the fragments that you were
simulating basically okay then our next
question how do you know if it's a
methylated cytosine or just a CT
mutation this is something that you
cannot really know but that usually
doesn't matter that much because you're
comparing samples and you're only
interested in differences between
samples usually so in all projects we
are interested in differential
methylation so meaning in one sample it
would be most two T's in the other
samples would be mostly C's and then of
course we know this is not a somatic
mutation probably but it is differential
methylation the only way we need to find
out would
to do also normal ivory so an
unconverted library and sequences alone
and then you would find those those
mutations as well you can compare so if
this is interesting I'd recommend to
have an unconverted library sequence
along okay then it looks like we have
time for one more question
do you consider using our scripting or
our programming for bisulfate sequencing
data analysis yeah I think actually so I
when I joined the book clip I was
actually mostly a better person so I
developed this obvious protocol and it
also got me interested in doing some
parts of the analysis and I think one of
the best things I did in this regard was
to start using art even though it might
not be made in terms of I think
computational people would say that
python is probably more elegant and
easier the syntax is easier but I'll
just provide you access to all those
biological databases and there's so many
interesting packages for awesome
information analysis I think it's a
really good platform to do the analysis
great well we do want once again thank
Paul darling earth for bringing us this
presentation today and of course thank
our sponsor diet G note for making the
webcast possible before we wrap up Paul
do you have any concluding thoughts for
our audience so I would just like to
thank everyone for your attention you
can see it's already getting a bit dark
behind me this is because it's evening
here in Vienna so I compute this and I
wish you a good evening from Vienna and
have a nice day
thanks for listening thank you of course
to Paul we hope you have a good evening
thank you again to diet you note for
making today's webcast possible
I want to let our attendees note that
this broadcast is going to be avail
available for on-demand replay you'll be
receiving an email from lab roots
alerting you when it's available and we
would invite you to form with that email
to any of your colleagues who might have
missed post live presentation today
that's all we have for now
nope we'll see you again good bye